-I want to show a picture.
I follow you also -- I follow
you on Instagram, as well.
You posted --
This was very sweet.
It said,
"I know genies don't have feet,
but you left some big shoes
to fill.
Rest in peace, Robin."
That must have been --
-Fan art. A fan made that, man.
[ Applause ]
-It's beautiful.
-Yeah.
-But you know, it was really --
I got presented the idea
to play the genie in "Aladdin,"
you know, and the first thing
is, "Hell no."
You know, it's like, you know,
when Robin Williams
smashed that role, you know.
And it's like, when you look at
things like that,
you always try to find, like,
what would you do differently?
What would you add to that?
So I looked at it
and the first thing was,
I didn't feel like
I wanted to touch it.
But then I spent some time with
it, and, you know,
I met with the directors
and talked about it.
-I think you're perfect.
-Oh, thank you, man.
-I think you're perfect
for the role.
Absolutely a great decision.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Phenomenal, man.
-Thank you.
Quest will know this.
What did it for me, when I was
messing with the music,
there's a song,
"A friend like me,
you ain't never had a friend
like me."
So, when we went in, I had him
grab "Impeach the President"
by the Honeydrippers,
and he used the drums off --
[ Drums beating ]
Yeah, standard old school.
♪ Ali Baba, he had them
forty thieves ♪
♪ Scheherazade,
he had a thousand pair ♪
♪ But, Master, you're in luck
because up your sleeve ♪
♪ You got a brand of magic ♪
♪ You got some power
in your corner now ♪
♪ Heavy ammunition
in your camp ♪
♪ You got some punch, pizzazz,
yahoo, and ow ♪
♪ All you got to do
is rub that lamp ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This guy can do everything.
Come on!
When you see this movie,
it is a big, big movie.
-Yeah, it is fantastic, man.
-I mean, dude, the dancing.
No spoilers.
-No, it's everything.
It's singing, dancing,
rapping, acting.
-There's elephants.
-Special effects.
-There's monkeys.
It is -- Live action.
-Live action.
It is so huge.
It's like the Prince Ali parade.
There's 1,000 extras
and animals.
-And they're all real.
-And all of that
in this sequence.
It is some of
the biggest dance --
-It's funny.
-It's funny, yeah.
It's just spectacular.
-That was very impressive. Yeah.
-No spoilers.
-Exactly.
People do not like spoilers.
-I want to show a clip
from "Aladdin."
Let's take a look. Will Smith.
-Hey, can you make me a prince?
-There is a lot of gray area
in "make me a prince."
I could just make you a prince.
-Oh, no.
-Right, you'd be snuggled up
with that dude
for the rest of your life.
-Yo, y'all see my palace?
-Be specific with your words.
The deal is in the detail.
-Got it.
-Which I don't
really understand
because if she already likes
you, why change?
-I told you -- she has to
marry a prince.
-I just want to go home, man.
-Okay, I can do that.
-Will Smith. "Aladdin."